Okay, welcome again Dr. Cutters and our easy easy steps here. First step is to we got to start with the basics here
Okay, let's let's decide where we're going to start. It's okay. I'll give you a ton of information
Got more information to give you to and I've tons of bonus packs on this course. That's for sure
But sometimes it's like drinking from a firehouse. Sometimes too much information is not good
If
We don't have a plan. So let's break this down and let's develop a plan. Let's get organized in our brain here a little bit
I know I've said that in a perfect world. We want to look at our sides and symptoms and
To get a good history and do
Very specific testing. Do we have an active antigen? Do we have an active toxicity? Do we have latent toxicities?
We have damaged barriers for sure. We have specific food allergies. Do we have other antibodies to other
Self tissues, you know, do we're asking ourself? Do I have a you know
An autoimmune disease and what stage of autoimmune disease am I in?
If I have an autoimmune disease, do I have just an autoimmune disease to one tissue?
Or do I have it to multiple organs? Do I have a systemic autoimmune disease? Do I have neurological antibodies?
Do I have damaged microglial cells? What are called prime microglial cells?
I have different toxicities. Do I have active Lyme disease? These are all tons of questions that can be very
Overwhelmed in hand. The first one was dig into these things. I'm very objective and very pragmatic. Let's figure this out
Let's get down to it. If you want to start as a full member with us
So we're glad to have you and we'll dig through this with you
But I know everybody's not ready for that. That's okay
Okay, so sometimes this is just too overwhelming. We need to be honest with ourselves
That's what this course is for. It's not to get you guys to be patient or something like that
It's to get you guys to be able to help yourself
We have to be honest. What can I afford? This stuff is expensive. Maybe you
You've gone through your finances and you just can't afford to do anything else
How much support do you have at home? Maybe your spouse is not supportive of everything you're doing
Maybe your family is a spade your stressor for you
Just be honest with yourself. It's okay
What are you willing to do? Are you willing to make lifestyle changes?
And then what can you actually do? Maybe somebody's really willing to make a lot of lifestyle changes
But you're raising four kids or five kids and you just can't stick to something
Okay, don't beat yourself up
Okay, give yourself grace. Give yourself mercy gods. Verses are new for you every single day
Okay, he just wants you to climb up on his lap
And he wants to hold you and he wants to tell you everything is gonna be okay
So
This course is not to overwhelm you and that's not what my desire is for you. But I also
You don't want to give you as much information as possible that you can work through it
Maybe you're just gonna catch some little nuggets
Well, these easy peasy steps will help you walk through that. Okay, that's what the goal of this is
Help you walk through a lot of this yourself and you can notice major changes. So don't get discouraged
Keep working through this. Oh gods got you know that we're praying for you